every time because they're Cynthia as a
character in the movie and then Stefan I
would be like like one of the few people
that machine SIA Shin seniority of eg
Canada yes what's your last name
purity burger cheese yeah go chance yeah
so before we get into it congrats on the
upcoming birth of your baby daughter can
you talk about the happiness about that
and becoming a dad again amazing I mean
I don't know what else to say you know
you just first of all imagine me saying
I'm just not of that into it I just am
into it I love every aspect of it I'm
just not one of those people that are
just like ah you know it is what it is
and she wanted I loved I loved I love
being a dad my daughter was just here
having lunch it was a great and I'm it
just I love being around kids I'm very
lucky I feel very fortunate people have
brought in gifts it's been really nice
it's fun it's almost embarrassing it's
good it is a good time it's that's
always a good time you know
professionally is one thing and then
there's the personal that's very special
professionally doing fantastic -
excellent movie can you talk about
reprising her role as Matt no no it was
interesting to me to get you know you
never know especially Danny was gonna do
the first one you know I mean sorry the
second one and you know he couldn't
because he had in another movie going on
and he actually had another movie going
on and he actually wanted to do it so
you bring people in and you go look we
got away with making it good movie which
is very rare so we really want to do
this but the story
Taylor's such a special writer you know
this story was so good you just like
look there's enough here to be able to
start to pull apart and and explore and
all that I liked exploring that
characters in a deeper level a more
multi-dimensional level you don't really
get to know them in the first one you
know whereas this one you kind of start
to see the cracks and you get in there
and there's a little more humanity and
confusion and you know just the stakes
are yeah so it was fun it was a fun
process good to see you and Benicio
together again which I always love you
know we've worked together five times
now and you know we've known each other
for 30 years so an opportunity to work
together is always attractive to us
you know you guys are taking a second go
at this and you talked about working
together before if you could like think
about a film that you've started in
previously that you might want to
revisit again is there one that sticks
out in your mind you know we did the
first thing that we worked on was this
thing called barrio Knights it was it
was a two-part episode for the series
that I was doing called Private Eye and
I had a really good time I thought he
was such an interesting you know we were
both young so I'm looking at this actor
and he was a total standout in every way
just in the most freakish way and the
most incredible professional way so but
would like to reprise it that'd be just
funny for us to do but is there some
maybe maybe inherent vice to really
interesting characters I love the
character that he played inherent vice
and my character was pretty wacky that'd
be fun what about one outside of Benicio
maybe the Goonies that's what the
Goonies
hmm if you want okay yeah what would he
play no not him just you separately if I
know you oh been easier oh I did have to
say The Goonies yes you can kick it up
no maybe it's tried to happen for 34
years 33 years it's tried to happen
we've had different scripts five
different scripts or something like that
but we haven't why do it if you haven't
found you know what I mean
that movies so much fun by itself it's
like I don't know if we want to continue
that but you never know you never know I
mean I'm still alive so well you know
there's always possibility